guys i'm coming on the road i would love
to see you we've been having a blast
just go to
salvolcanocomedy.com for all tickets uh
i'm at the ryman in march 11th i uh the
next day i am at the tivoli theater in
chattanooga then we got all sorts of fun
stuff we got louisville we got
evansville we got tulsa and okc oklahoma
you've been asking me to come there i am
on the way get those right away um the
beacon theater my hometown i've been
banging that drum a lot but this will be
my first headline ever that's may 14th
and then of course i have san diego and
la may 21st and 22nd love to see you
guys please come on out folks march 10th
through the 12th i will be in
philadelphia pa
at the punchline comedy club i think
it's three shows maybe four maybe five
i think it's five i think it's five
shows you gotta come out to one of them
then on april 14th i'm going to be in
irvine california at the irvine improv
one show only 8 pm that night then i'm
heading right
down to san diego from there to do a
bunch of shows i'm going to be in austin
texas
may 20th and 21st to win four shows at
the creek and cave
come out to see all these things and
also if you're in new york city
come to joey rose's if you're interested
in stand up and comedy shows go to joe
derosa info.com for tickets and
information if you're interested in
coming to the bar and sandwich shop i've
opened go to joeyrosesnyc.com
for info and hours and everything else
and there's a new secret sandwich called
the disgusting pig
swish
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right hey
folks welcome to t-a-s-t-e
buds we're the taste buds sal and joe uh
and our guest today is matteo elaine a
dear dear friend dear friend hysterical
comedian wonderful human being because
they're so wild
i mean the amount of it's like it's like
pandemonium in here shifting constant
shifting energy happy angry sad
concentrating oh yeah i'd like to say
it's not my fault
it's more cell
wow it's more so wow it's more so you
know what i need to say that the
listeners know it's more listen it's
more you listen i mean look pimp's got
it on tape and we will bring that
footage to the fans of the debate on
what this episode was please please
bring it i think you bullied me i didn't
bully you i'm not here to bully you i
love you and i support you that's
manipulation
[Applause]
he bullied me into taking a clear with
him against matteo you know what let's
put up the video and leave it up to the
fans if joe's a bully yeah yes but but
no no i'm not a bully
and this is what i will say
sal tried to do
so the battle today is eclair versus
uh cannoli which makes sense
sal was trying to argue that we could
that he should be team
uh croissant and i was saying you can't
do croissant because it's too broad of a
pastry versus another two in the history
of this show we have never put a label
on what we can and can't do ever that's
not true i was just trying to make a
third uh third dog in the fight and we
looked up popular pastries and i was
gonna see if any responded to me and one
was a strudel it didn't one was a danish
i think the thing about croissants i
mean it yes i understand like it is fun
to have a you know a three-way but um
the problem with the croissant is it's
not as it's not it's as specific as a
cannoli is specific exactly this is a
hard shell with ricotta filling yeah and
you can there's variables of like well
isn't it
but but ins is the croissant do you put
jam on it is there chocolate inside is
it almonds
sandwich at burger king with sausage egg
and cheese on it this is what i'm saying
you could eat croissant as your bread
for lunch to make a salad it's more of a
bread which is makes it more malleable
you know it's like it could be i
understand what you cannoli is like this
is it we have it at this time of day
what you were trying to do was this
mateo and i were going okay uh mateo was
going i'll do whiskey and i was saying
okay i'll do rum and then you were going
i'm gonna do coca-cola and you go no
no no we were just about to do a ham and
cheese versus a hot dog last episode
they're both lunch foods that you eat i
mean
i would you could pull it back yeah you
could pull back as much as you want once
a year
no you know you're full of [ __ ] right
now really yes yes really stop i don't
know
and then by the way the fans will see
this in the video when i said sal since
we disagree let's just be team eclair
because we both want to argue
you start saying crazy [ __ ] like i feel
bad that we might be ganging up on the
guest what the [ __ ] no i didn't say i
felt bad i just said that like the
dynamic might be more it might be better
if we have three different points of
view university and universities you
know remember when he said he felt bad
ganging up well i said that you were
here i said that i'm about to go back on
grindr
i said that i'm in a heated mood and
it's been a while since we've been
heated you see why we drink yeah you
should ever drink no i can't imagine
it's 5 p.m i got shows tonight if i'm
now he stops
at 9 a.m
i want to say that i'm not wearing a
shirt on my own face uh if you don't see
it it says nicholas cage it's supposed
to be funny and kitschy so
don't look at this and be like what the
[ __ ] and also i just want a new merch
i just want to tell the fans the video
they're referencing will be at the very
end of this episode on youtube okay show
it and i actually left playing out yeah
we'll see that i am once again wearing
merch of my one of my best pals merch
despite how he treats me
i still wear his merch and support him
i'm sitting in your place of business
thank you joey roses we're here right
now 174 rivington street come on down
kids come on down we're open tuesday
through sunday go to
joeyrosesnyc.com for times hours
whatever it is if you want to order
online we're here we're back in the rose
room right now we're having a good time
welcome is this what you call a good
time just show us a blast if we say
we're having a good time
we're having a good year you're not used
to this regardless
you're used to supportive friends
supportive i was trying to make fun of
you too i was trying to make fun of you
to rosebud baker okay and i said i i
i think you were singing on instagram or
something
i'm tired of matteo singing i want to
trash him and she said mateo can do no
wrong i will not go there with you and i
said just trash him with me because
that's what we do is trash people and
she refused i thought to myself they
have a different type of friendship than
i have no no you're very hurt on him i
promise you my friends are
drag queens and vicious gay men we are
not nice to each other we are vicious to
each other i promise you and rosebud and
i were pretty vicious i mean she's great
rosebud and i have trashed so many
people together but whatever
she wouldn't do it oh that rosebud
you have my heart
[Music]
i love you
[Music]
multifaceted and talented it always
blows me away oh thank you you're very
funny you can sing like a [ __ ]
you you just you're so sweet you are
like steeped in your own culture
you're an amazing artist and
check out his instagram i mean you are
you have the body of an adonis thank you
it's chiseled
how much work do you have to put into
that you don't drink
i don't i drink every blue moon i'm just
not a drinker i don't know i don't enjoy
how how how many days a week and how
many hours a week are you in the gym
four or five days a week and just like
an hour or 45 minutes so it's more diet
it's like you just have to watch what
you eat how much you eat but you eat but
you indulge you indulge yeah but i
indulge because i work out a lot so
there'll be times when i'm like okay
i'll have pasta or i'll you know but
you're also starting with metabolism
you're also starting with a tremendous
foundation maintenance that's what they
say right with the body maintaining is
easy
establishing inside
you just came at me so serious i thought
i was talking to a contractor i was like
what is it like you're hunched over
you're looking at me in the eye you're
like you all know that the most
important thing about the body is the
maintenance i'm like
why are you yelling i don't know what's
happening no it's always fun it is
maintenance yeah yeah they say
maintenance is easy establishing is hard
that's right oh so you've established
long ago
like five years ago i started working
you're like a thomas's english muffin
you established long ago 1800s and yeah
yes me too so so what is so five hours a
week you're in there
do you mix up the routine is it there's
muscle confusion is it all that stuff
you just i followed this
crunches
no i don't do crunches
i should do more abs i don't ever do abs
um your abs are a washboard come on but
that's diet that's the diet really so my
diet i get amps yes really yeah yeah
what do i have to eat shrubs um well
everything at this table
i'm like wait about a minute you're
telling me
[Laughter]
i know no but so so so do you feel you
work hard at maintaining or do you feel
like you coast it's part of your life i
feel like it's no big deal so it's like
um so a part of my i it was hard work to
make it feel normal does that make sense
it does so there was a while like i
don't want to go to the gym i don't want
to eat this much i don't want to do this
i'm lazy bubba and then i'm like well
you feel better afterwards have you
always looked like this do you know i
used to be i want to see what i used to
look like yes i do i used to be i'm
right now a hundred and
you're my eighth grade weight so
continue i'm 100 well this is what i
used to look like i was
125 pounds oh i don't even recognize you
i know
oh my god i do not recognize you
whatsoever i don't want to have a
boundary i have a before and after on my
instagram if you just scroll down my
friend i don't recognize you you look
like not you look amazing but this this
does not look like you
oh my god
[Laughter]
you look like a doctor just told you
like you're not gonna make it like a
doctor said it's fatal but how long ago
is that but here's the this is why i was
23 but i mean that's the weight i was
when i moved to new york and you're now
you're 24.
no i'm 35. but here's the thing
here's the thing this is why you were i
would kill to look like that i would
tell kill
this is why you were better off or even
easier ride than me and sal
this is like building on fresh land
when he
[Laughter]
that deep my entire life never ever ever
and and odds are out the jury's out i
won't be able to in the future either he
built he built on top of this what you
and i need to do is the equivalent of
knocking down the old building right
building which is so much harder yeah
so much harder yeah i'll never do it
well
and i don't doubt that
yeah who's this lady you're with her
name is charlotte she's from london and
that's us in italy we were at a painting
school in italy okay okay let me ask you
a question you still have to get to the
point in the gym for you to feel
satisfied where you're pushing yourself
will you feel the soreness
or is that just like smoking like
exactly just doesn't necessarily
represent um hard work always um i mean
it does in a sense that like you want to
like rip apart your your muscles so that
they rebuild and then and eat well
enough to help that process and then
build on top of that all that stuff i
was bulking for a while i hired a coach
and she's great name is arya she's
awesome arya shine on instagram and but
i told her i was like i travel so much i
can't bulk she sends me my meals like i
don't want my meals this is you no no
but i was trying to bulk to shred back
down but it's too hard i was like i
can't why does that mean why bulk to
shred down why not just shred up
it doesn't quite work that way i don't
understand these things yeah yeah well
yeah so i don't know what you're talking
about this is the way
well here's what i'm talking about when
you get a piece of sculpture a a piece
of marble the sculpture's inside
the shrimp that's a way to get to the
david you see what i'm saying yeah you
simply chipped away what wasn't there
that's true i was yeah i was i was
attacking on i'm a little like dolly
parton um yeah but but yeah so it just
anyways i'm like this is the way it all
be and then just maintain because that's
easier to do otherwise like eating six
meals a day and then i was feeling puffy
buffy is where i live
i will tell you right now i
one thing i do my entire life is i keep
uh people in my life all right so uh i
grow with people and i try not to lose
touch with the best of the best and so i
net out where i keep in contact with a
very vast group of people from different
categories in my life and it it's work
it's work uh because to maintain a
substantial relationship and rapport
with that many different people across
that many time periods in that many
geographical areas you really are
working but i i keep the people in my
life that are amazing and uh and i move
forward so all this to say that i know a
lot of people i keep in contact with a
lot of people there are two people
in my life of many
that can wear a speedo
okay
you and stavros yeah yeah
did you see all the pictures of salvos
and i did today
that's amazing and he is safe to say the
the opposite of you but he he he owns it
but i'm but i'm jealous of stavros for
the same reason for similar reasons that
i'm jealous of mateo
stavros can is one of those guys that
can be out of shape
and it just looks like he's supposed to
just be that way um when i get out of
shape i gain weight in odd places so i
get tits i have a gut i gain weight in
all the places what somebody wants
excuse me somebody once said to me like
you know the thing with james gandolfini
was
he was broad-shouldered and he could
just have this big gut and which is kind
of like i'm a big guy deal with it i
feel like stavros is like that i'm not
like that i guess keith says you don't
have shoulder yeah yeah exactly and i so
i gained weight in a very weird way
did you see george robinson yeah keith
robinson and i were dating during the
pandemic i'm not kidding
we were literally dating dinner's
everything you came to some of those
every week we're like okay where are we
getting dinner this week we're hanging
out the cellar yeah but do you know what
you mean yeah yeah it's so it's real
torturous but also too it is how one
carries themselves i mean i know that
sounds like a cliche but really how you
feel on the inside does mirror the
outside world so there is a certain way
that star wars is carrying himself that
is that permeates don't get me wrong
i think i'm a [ __ ] tank well we're
gonna we need to we need to whittle you
back down
you should not be walking around with
this much confidence
it works
i opened a bar i don't give a [ __ ]
a bar with chris this is my nana's
basement it's like christmas decorations
up in almost march pictures of old wops
that no one remembers
you know what i mean i love the inner
semester we wanted this room to feel
kind of like a grandmother
would feel very at home and the
chandelier and stuff i do have to take
down these crit i kind of still like
them there but i do need to take them
it's good no keep it it really reminds
me of my grandma's house i'm not kidding
yeah yeah yeah maybe i will yeah i love
you know i love christmas i'm number one
i'm moving christmas number one number
one real quick before we move on since
we're all italian here did everyone
yeah but you're raised by a talent i
identify
okay
thanks brooklyn all right so
what what i mean is like
why are you coming at me you're coming
at me more than you're going upstairs
it
is bothering me you're sitting like a
father of seven he's looking at you like
you're a human in the mouth watching
your family grow take those fingers
apart
[Laughter]
people i just bring it out of people
they like to come at me you know what it
is i've been influenced by keith
robinson i was a good person until i
became friends with keith yeah
i had a clear
soul
and then i would love to be on keith's
side because we do argue well together
but then trash out too though well we'll
move to south but
but um
but also you know what i meant so i'm
saying is like do we have relatives with
two kitchens in the house one upstairs
one downstairs this is a normal thing
yeah no that's that was not a hundred
really but the kitchen was a sacred
place even though there was only one but
yes i hear you i i know
i know that you go to the bashamen yeah
that was that was a little in in
pennsylvania that was a little more
something you saw in the city for some
reason like in um uh the city homes like
the row homes and stuff that had
basements
uh you'd go down and sometimes it was
kind of fixed
that you could almost live down there
you know what i mean so there was a k
another kitchen downstairs or whatever
that was something you saw less for some
reason in the suburbs where i grew up
even though there were basements i don't
know what that is the suburbs had
unfinished basements they were more like
there were like playrooms and stuff it
wasn't even that it was more like here's
where you keep your tools and your pipes
and
you don't even scare your kids yeah this
is
we wanted to make a room that could
flood okay for a year
it was like that you know yeah but um
but yeah but anyway i'm sorry finish
with you that was it i just i'm with two
italians i wanted to ask
uh italian adjacent i mean look i i
ziggs when i should have zagged with
this
i was talking to pimp earlier i should
have [ __ ] steered into this arab
thing that i have
i'd be making a lot more money right now
yeah yeah but i just don't like that
we're both italian latin mix yes the
correct i identify with the italians
that's how i was raised i mean i i'm
part mexican but i was raised by
italians so culturally i'm italian but i
mentioned i'm like i'm also mexican i
mentioned that i'm arab too but you got
to really steer into it if you want to
make some you're an egyptian right yeah
over there you could be a millionaire
right
you could be a millionaire yeah i know
you went the wrong way it's like when i
filled out my student loan application i
checked caucasian to this day i don't
know why i could have just checked
hispanics
you know you gotta have a story i gotta
go i felt sorry a place is the only arab
in the italian neighborhood
i was just not like italians and arabs
blood in italians anyway so a lot of
italians hat we all sort of look great i
will tell you that wherever you're
sending your tape in to try to get a new
special just dress in arabic clothing
send that [ __ ] in and you will have a
special post taste i know you'll
definitely get attention
i don't know how it will be perceived
but you will get attention
um
i'll call it i'll call it isn't this
bizarre but i'll spell it bizarre like
an arab market
[Music]
i come from the time of adoption where
they gave you a little more information
than they were supposed to right so
that's how i know but then i did twenty
three and you could be royal ancestry oh
what did it say i'm curious
mostly egyptian yeah a little bit of
middle eastern not a little bit 30
saudi arabia that area um yeah it's kind
of how fascinating
it is fascinating but it's just it it
doesn't mean anything because it's like
when you grow up
completely out of it i never met another
arab kid until i was 20 years old you
know what i mean because where i grew up
was all irish polish and a roman
catholic that's what it was so
i just didn't
i respect it i appreciate it i feel a
little like oprah right now i'm like
yeah i see you as a doctor
tell us about the pyramids
my point is is like i i can't like
pretend like people have said to me many
times like you should exploit it so you
can get more well i but i can't
i never met a gay person another gay
person until i was in my 20s right and
i'm really riding that
i know but here's the difference
if i felt like
oh my god i only want to have sex with
arab people
i could have steered into it do you know
what i mean that's the difference with
gay gay you were like
i i might not have met other gay people
but god damn
i feel it you know what i mean because i
don't well you could don't want to be
straight you could learn arabic and
egyptian egyptian arabic is like the
standard arabic for television learning
arabic is not the same thing as being
driven from a romantic place of sexual
what i'm saying to you outside of my my
outside of my gain is like okay i speak
spanish right right so even though i
wasn't raised with a mexican culture
right but i mean my family is part
mexican it's an instant connection with
other latinos so i can have full
conversations with other latinos in
spanish if they don't speak english and
there's an immediate connection just i
didn't even i didn't i would never learn
italian
even though i would you could learn
arabic i don't want to that would well
then so much fun
i don't want to i don't want to i hear
you but you're also you're you're a guy
that wants to know
different languages were you born here i
just don't know yeah chicago i was born
in chicago okay i hear the chicago have
you ever looked into your background
like what if you're a prince
okay obviously
[Laughter]
i had a joke about this
i had a joke about this about you know
you could be this i don't want a kingdom
yeah i don't want to do the bit
i don't want to do the bit by the way
was that offensive what i said when i
said no not at all because
pimp is over there doing his gen z [ __ ]
where he's going oh my god what oh yeah
no you're bringing it up on an episode
about applesauce so whatever you're
doing
no we're talking about like i think it's
inch i think if you have interest and
your background this is what i'm this is
what i was trying to say about the uh
sexual identity versus heritage oh i was
just using it as a joke
no no i'm not taking it seriously i
think it's an interesting conversation
and i couldn't choose croissants yeah
but this is interesting because when
you're when you're
we know them we love them they call
better help and they sponsor this
podcast okay we've uh used them from
time to time since uh since having a
relationship with them in the past year
we have suggested it to people and i
have seen firsthand how people uh really
benefit from better help and that's why
we keep them on the pod and we keep
working with them uh relationships take
work a lot of us drop anything to help
someone else but we don't really focus
on ourselves and self-care especially
after what we're coming out of is
paramount and that's why something like
this is something you should finally
check out if you haven't before this
month betterhelp online therapy wants to
remind you to take care of your most
important relationship the one you have
with yourself uh you know you hit the
gym you make time for a haircut or even
trying actual therapy you are your
greatest asset invest some time in
yourself and effort in yourself like you
do for other people okay better help is
online therapy it offers video phone and
even live chat sessions with a therapist
okay you don't have to see anyone on
camera if you don't want to so not only
do you have to leave you don't have to
leave your house you do not have to be
on camera which is which is it really uh
is a benefit to a lot of people who that
is their big barrier to doing this kind
of thing it's more affordable as well uh
than in person therapy and you can be
matched with a therapist if you sign on
in under 48 hours so it is quick uh give
it a try and see why over two million
people have used betterhelp online
therapy
again i tell you this podcast is
sponsored by betterhelp and tastebuds
listeners get 10
off their first month at betterhelp.com
tastebuds again check it out that's b e
t t e r h e l p dot com slash taste buds
better help slash taste there it is
now i need to log on quick i'll tell you
right now
factor is what we're talking about
factor a factor got sent to my home tell
me what factors in factor is pretty tell
me what the factors are it's
pre-packaged portion meals um
tailored by you and what your diet needs
to be uh and because we when we ever
establish a relationship with these
companies they send us their product so
we can try them firsthand and i will
tell you right now i loved factor i went
through all my meals the first week and
i literally became a customer and
ordered it again i was drinking these
banana strawberry smoothies for
breakfast which were legit and low in
sugar and and and you can't find that in
the juice and they were delicious so i
would start finding a juice you can't
what happened i know
you can't find low sugar you really
can't i'm not making a joke i know i
know and i'm serious i'm not
no joke i get home like eight nine
o'clock i'm starving as well and i heat
up my meal in two minutes my factory
meal and there was everything from
chicken to beef to shrimp uh and they're
all they were all everything i got was
within five to six hundred calories they
were all carb conscious so you can
actually pick whatever you like love it
factor makes it easy for us to eat clean
24 7 and fresh they're never frozen they
came completely fresh they're prepared
meals they're delicious and you they're
actually good for you okay it saves us
time uh they're chef crafted meals so
they come to your doorstep um i love
that they tackle
the sort of intimidating tough things
you know what i mean because they
haven't died they actually have
registered dietitians and expert chefs
working hands in hand with them there
are 29 meal options a week so you're not
going to get bored there that's awesome
and that's important and you do get
bored with a diet so that's important
and so this is for people uh that have
all different types of preferences vegan
and veggie meals keto meals low calorie
options cold pressed juices which i
mentioned smoothies energy bites
plant-based bars they have everything
they make it easy if you're looking for
convenience and healthy this is it
factor head to go dot factor 75 so
go.factor75.com
tastebuds one two zero now gotta tell
you a factor asks a lot of you as far as
the address field goes but when you get
it when you type it all in
you're gonna enjoy it you use the promo
code
taste buds one two zero you're gonna get
a hundred twenty dollars off that's
amazing yeah all right you can buy code
yeah that's code tastebuds120 at
geo.factor75.com
tastebuds120 for 120 off
when you know you're arab
but you don't necessarily look different
from everybody around you right you
might be an arab right you might be an
arab if there you go do you have a
monkey that steals you apples
do you have a long curved sword for no
apparent reason
you might be an arab
anyway
you if i had looked incredibly different
than the white people surrounding me
sure i might have had a long time to
find oh i do too but i might have had a
longing to find others you know what i
mean
we're we're where's what you're saying
with the where you didn't mean another
gay person it doesn't matter you still
knew like no i'm i need to meet other
people like me i never felt like oh i'm
very different because everybody around
me just kind of looked like me i think
you know what i'm saying yeah but i'm
just saying you like podcasts so it
would be really interesting if you went
in a deep dive to find out more about
your heritage i wish you
egypt i've done listen trust me i've
been down this road i i have had
multiple projects that have been bought
about me going out to find
the the lineage and and the fat and they
always fall apart for some reason and
they never come to fruition
but i've been paid a lot of money to sit
in an apartment and write out and this
is how you spent it where
yeah this is a great way to spend it
it's actually [ __ ] brilliant
[Laughter]
anymore or wherever the [ __ ] it is uh so
that's why i did this but anyway the
point is is that i um
i
i it's it's i've had many i've
many projects it never for whatever
reason it never comes to fruition maybe
you have to believe a little more
if you believe and i kind of don't care
my parents are my parents you know well
i don't think i don't think you're gonna
go to egypt and find your aunt and uncle
be like [ __ ] my parents i'm moving here
i mean it's just kind of cool you know
but we had a lost connection my mom did
with her or my mexican grandpa right and
he left her her and their family when
she was young and then when her was
adopted my grandma remarried a sicilian
and was adopted by the ceiling my
grandma was italian so she was raised
italian but when she was in her 30s she
found my mexican family again and they
reconciled and all this other stuff and
then he would start sending his letters
and so it was kind of like she's not
denying her father my grandpa who's
sicilian that he's you know her father
and raised her it just was a part of her
that she wanted to discover and she did
it sure i get that i don't have that
interest i guess okay it's it's it's i'm
not i'm not disinterested but i feel
pretty fulfilled with my family so i
guess it's sort of like saying
yeah dude you know
to to to a rock star for instance hey
dude you're famous but you've been with
the same woman since high school
you could have any woman you want and
they go
i don't know if this analogy works out
yeah who does that he does that i don't
know
the guy goes i'm fulfilled i found the
person no okay we're talking about you
you said you were like if i had just
said i was arab i would be a millionaire
i was joking i'm joking okay got it and
then i was like well find it no i don't
want to find them no no no i'm saying
i'm joking like i didn't i i could never
fake the passion for it got it so when
people say to me why don't you steer
into it i'm like i don't understand what
you want me to do like i can't like just
fake it but trust me when i tell you if
you think i know a lot of people that
did i know a lot of people that i'm just
saying if you faked a little more we
could get some crown molding in here
think about it for
decorations know a lot of people that
all of a sudden their last name i'm
going to change my last name to this now
oh gotcha oh that's interesting okay wow
oh really how convenient that you just
now have discovered see now started by
matteo when i was 18 for facebook
because my aunt cindy said change
because i was living in italy at the
time so obviously you're mateo in italy
and she was like when you remember on
facebook you would get fired for you
there were pictures of you drinking
remember that and we of course i'm
working at michael's but um which i was
fired from anyways for stealing and uh
what yeah
yeah michael's crafts michael's arts and
crafts oh yes and uh did you steal
what'd you tell thousands of dollars
thousands of dollars they caught me with
a winnie poo cake pan but it was
thousands of dollars and um my aunts and
he said just don't have your like
government name on there so i just put
down mateo
and then ever since what is your
government matteo matthew oh oh it is
good matt yeah oh okay it's legit on
your birth certificate matthew mm-hmm oh
interesting there's 18 and then of
course by the time i got into comedy i'm
already going by mateo right but it
suits you so well it does suit me yeah
it's also like you know it was a smart i
mean i know it wasn't strategic but it
wasn't like i was happy yeah
yeah yeah so i have three a three-fold
question they don't have anything to do
with each other one
how did you get so fluent in uh italian
uh with the actual great pronunciation
uh living in chicago you just steeped in
the family i just only spoke because
your your your enunciation is spot on
and then did you learn spanish because
spanish is a nice satellite off of
italian and you were able to consume it
that way or how did you do that
basically yeah so i would i would i
learned learned learned italian living
in italy because i'd go back and visit
either somebody or family friends i go
for like two months at a time i started
going when i was like 15.
so you just you have to i mean you're in
the middle of sicily like right no one
speaks english so i would just come back
like
like you're just like perfectly anytime
but spanish i learned i was sort of like
splotchy how i learned i mean it's so
close to italian that you know most
italians where they just hear spanish
they don't have to really they
understand like 80 of it truly
and um but then i started living with my
friend felicia she's from mexico and so
we lived together for two years and i
was like okay only speak spanish to me
and we'd only watch spanish tv and only
we still only speak spanish that's rough
only you kept to that oh i loved it but
i love learning languages i learned
french i was telling german when i was
younger so i just learned spanish that
way but i have an italian accent in
spanish so it's humiliating oh bye
every time i talk to latinos like you
sound like mario like i sound like a
complete like hey
[Laughter]
isn't it a crime by the way that that
guy that guy helped the guy the voice of
mario has made mario become so popular
as how has been the greatest uh is it
one guy yeah is it one guy yeah it's one
guy over the years no i think that's not
true the mario boys
maybe i could finish my point before you
step on it
sorry open up the polls i'm arguing
croissants oh maybe i could finish my
point
that chris pratt is now doing it in the
movie i think that's disgraceful that's
what i was getting at
i think it's disgraceful it's like this
guy is the voice of mario this is the
guy
well so the mario voice i believe they
got the first mario voice the first
mario voice the iteration of his voice
was the cartoon in the late 80s early
90s yes
it was more italian right no it's total
brooklyn plumber and then when mario 64
came out
that's the voice that we all know today
the
one guy that's done it for the last 30
30 years yeah it's been 20 years
whatever it's been 25 years yeah his
name is charles charles something out
his day rate is 1200
he better work well we could we can get
him for 1200. he better [ __ ] work but
my point that's my point is like this
guy
everybody identifies mario now with that
voice yeah everybody
yes
yeah yeah yeah he does that then they
finally finally nintendo who has been
adverse to making movies for all these
years any intellectual any any
additional content of their intellectual
they're finally making a mario movie
animated and who do they get for mario
chris pratt
i mean what a snooze right um yeah what
is who do you think who would have been
good him the guy or me no but he has to
act yeah yeah no it's an already true
it's a cartoon yeah but you yeah but
he's not you have to start looking at
chris brown yeah he's running around
with [ __ ] dinosaurs
what does he know about it's a cartoon
there's a cartoon what does he have to
have oh it's a cartoon that's what i'm
saying oh okay i thought you said live
action no because he's doing the voice
of the games what do you think i closed
my eyes italian to not
spell
available
i know i know
i know my second part can i harmonize
with you sure you let me know what
please i i don't sing but you do but i
kind of wish i did but it'd be nice to
be easier if i harmonize a view so if
you picked a song and then i could
harmonize with you okay so what should i
sing uh what's the song of both
satellites i like like satellites
right let's do like
um silent night okay okay do you know
the words in silence
a little bit you know science yeah
night
oh
is calm
all is
bright virgin
mother and child
[Music]
[Music]
that was so much fun if we were
roommates wow
swear to god i would ask you to
harmonize everything i'm running
anything's funny because you help me
i just probably sound like a goon if you
take him out but when he when he goes in
he silks it up
[Applause]
i don't want to harmonize cerrone okay
[Laughter]
it was like a whole new world that's you
babe
you want me to walk off the bridge for a
suggesting satellite and you want me to
sing a whole new world what is
a whole new
that's a racist joke you just made it
and i hope you're sad you are we just
don't want you being a prince
i'm you made the joke about that with
your inheritance no but it's mine
that's right thank you very much
thank you very much why don't you go
sing uh la cucaracha you [ __ ] mexican
i'm the mexican i'm sorry whatever the
hell you are
he's cuban
yes and puerto rican
and also
so nervous gonna fall every time and
sal's defense you have gone on a rant
about
latinx one episode i didn't go on a rant
and i assure you
i don't even want to be involved in that
conversation no i didn't it wasn't a
rant i didn't know how to pronounce
latinx i didn't know if it was latinx or
latinx latina like christina like within
christine aguilera with the x it's it's
hard to predict it's a it's a strange
spelling of a word it's hard to
pronounce at first glance part three i'm
going to chicago this weekend uh and um
uh where should i eat
well
give me more like what do you want like
deep dish pizza like portillos do you
want italian beef you want a chicago hot
dog i think you tell me where you think
i should go barring anything if you want
deep dish pizza every dish every cuisine
sounds like a euphemism
you want a deep dish
you're an italian beast
just go to steamworks it's a it's a bath
house and you'll get all
you'll get deep dish well dipped
with an italian beef
a vienna beef they're from from austria
um i don't need to go to a um uh a
tourist spot i'm saying i'm actually
noticing deep
is the best and i've had that i did it
with uh what's the thing with you they
mail it to me now no no you don't want
that you want to go get it fresh yeah
get it fresh get it fresh um i even took
sam morrell the most new york human
being on the face of the planet raised
in manhattan and he took one bite of a
fresh lemonade and he was like wow this
is pretty good i'm going but you can
have one i mean if you have two you're
destroyed for the rest of the day yeah
yeah and then you can go to like al's
beef has great italian beef or
portillo's portillos has great
is a famous chicago chain that has i
feel the anger
these names
are so absurd that if you wrote a script
and you said it takes place in an inside
place called portillos right there we go
you have to change that it sounds racist
it doesn't really sound great
illuminati's
lumalnotties
illuminati is a whole other thing that's
so i'm gonna walk you there be like is
this illuminati
who what the house no but
we're lady gaga excuse me we're a lady
lady gaga by the way went on the biggest
rant no she's great you need to relax
because first of all she said she
studied a [ __ ] panther she's like i
was so into the role of patricia that i
studied how panthers moved you should
have studied an italian accent i swear
to god
i swear to god
when she walked on set she's like isn't
this for anastasia they're like no no
you're playing italian she's like got it
i mean
also the italians who watch the movie
like my friend paris i don't understand
they're from milan this is a northern
family why are they acting like a bunch
of napolitans they're acting like this
you're the only people who call it out
we can't so but here's the thing i
thought she was great sure
and you know who else jeremy is lady
gaga jeremy irons was my favorite who
didn't even break the english accent
i got the screener and i watched it i
really enjoyed it but this is my point
when i was first hearing about house of
gucci from uh i have another podcast go
we'll see you in hell and my co-host was
telling me about it because he saw it
before me and he was he was reading the
castle as he was going so he plays
paella gucci and she plays patrice and i
go dude if these weren't real names i
would be like you have to change these
names this sounds racist can i tell you
a quote they're the most italian names
i've ever heard but they're really wait
can i tell you but it was just funny can
i tell you i've been having a field day
with how funny lady gaga is in these
press interviews because she thought she
was getting nominated for an oscar and
one of them she goes hold on when she
goes when i was in the role of patricia
i felt
so involved in her that when i went to
go look at his grave i thought to myself
what have i done
no
we get it that's over the top
and suddenly meryl streep move aside
like i mean it's like i get it i'm glad
that you're into it but like it could
not like it's so nyu freshman year yeah
do you know what i mean it's like you're
getting paid millions of dollars relax
god i'm shocked at this take that you
have i love lady gaga and i love that
she's so ridiculous yeah i studied how
leopards and panthers moved why she's an
italian woman who murdered someone she's
not in a jungle in a tree
what are you talking about i will say
she is like a leopard or a panther in
that well she's a leopard panther who
was a russian princess who was misplaced
in france
study a leopard she just home just well
she went
she also wrote a dissertation how do you
study it youtube her movement did she
feel like youtube yeah she walked on she
was she walked on she's like
action don't you don't you get a youtube
with me
all right you said youtube eight times
i'm asking you you're asking how do i
study a leopard you watch video of it
it's a crazy question
she flew to the jungle boom and she put
on a costume i'm kidding she did i don't
know if she did anything
she actually she dressed up like cats on
broadway and stood in the jungle what
did you think of the cats movie one of
the most amazing things i've ever seen
i've literally had unwatchable i've had
diarrhea where i've i've like thought
back about how much better that was than
the movie cats
and you know what i watched cats don't
worry we're recording i watched
i watched
i
i watched cats with my friends and
during the beginning of the pandemic
together over zoom and we kept pausing
i was like this is i shouldn't watch
this is too like the end has come like
if we're here and what's his name james
corden yeah
i swear to god if i never saw james
corden again i wouldn't be sad yeah he
is unbearable
you don't mean that he's right
oh my god he didn't say i want him to
die i said if i never saw james corden
again i wouldn't be sad oh boy you're
getting to meet the corner
[Music]
i think i know what it is though because
i don't i don't hate bless us no i'm
kidding i'm just [ __ ] around
do you want me to be on team cannoli now
yeah you do by the way
i love you so much you're such a [ __ ]
to me but i still love you so much i'm
blaming keith i'm sorry i love you and
we talked about video games be mean to
this [ __ ] prick it's impossible
and then you physically struck me sounds
like a guy i'll show up
[Applause]
okay so sounds like guy you can't be mad
at him he'll show up two hours late to
something
and you'll be like i do hate people who
are late but two hours this guy i had a
guy in a date who was 30 minutes late 40
minutes late and i left
never on never but always there when you
call though always that's what i'm
saying you could i'm saying in theory
you're the kind of guy that could show
up two two hours late to your
to your daughter's birthday you'd be
furious
birthday her birth yeah exactly this was
her two hours really promised to be the
clown he walks up you go
as soon as you see him you go
it's all right buddy
you're being hard on me right now i'm
not i'm two hours i want to go
back in theory i said you're the kind of
guy in theory that could do something
like that crazy and you couldn't be mad
at you about it because you're so
lovable all right it's your heart it's
hard to be mad all right
can we triple harmonize would you do
that i don't know that song all right
let's do this song ready starts with me
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm gonna make a brand new
york new york i remember elizabeth nelly
doing that in new york new york but i
don't remember tonight you're a great
legend story oh i would love to you know
what would you think his answer is going
to be to that huh of course he does
because you love doing the livestream
thank you but this is maria kalas right
this is yeah my favorite opportunity yes
yes yes yes you see how i mentioned it
uh my friend is uh did musical theater
and stuff and he met
cannolis versus class folks cannolis
versus class
he met somebody that knew
uh liza okay
and they were tell they told him this
story and he then told me where he said
liza minnelli was going off to this guy
that they she knew about um
uh uh mel tour may oh development day
about melbourne she said blasphemous
quote apparently was allegedly was she
goes and then i'll do the quote she goes
she goes mel tormey mommy hated him
she said he was an awful man eyes like
poached eggs
all right ready
ask me about mel tormey i'll be
elizabeth oh yes yes
eliza did you yes male 2
no
i remember one time mama
who was so funny oh my god people don't
know this about mama she was really
funny
but
one time she said
male 2
just
had eyes like an easter
egg and it wasn't talent
oh my goodness this was so funny my
father was gay
how did you get there how did you get
that down eliza just a lot first time i
saw elizabeth at the michael jackson
30th anniversary special and i remember
she was wobbly and had a brain
encephalitis but even though she was
like like like
like a melted she had encephalitis
already oh she was recovering from it
wow and she came out and saying r
kelly's you are not alone to michael
jackson just beyond problematic uh
ironic as hell but i remember feeling a
certain way i'm thinking who is this
woman i'm intrigued by her like it was
just so naturally like how old were you
when you saw that i was it was like the
day before 9 11 so i was a sophomore in
high school well she's sweet
she is but she did a cbs morning
interview recently and she was quite
lucid but she's it's it's the days okay
but she's gotta be watching i have
shirts i don't know she's in her
seventies i've heard no no no
yes she is she's gotta be in her
eighties no she was in the seventies
when i was born how how old is liza
minnelli
because barbara streisand's younger
i've heard talk that she does like the
party a bit
are you out of your mind she's been the
back of the ambulances more than yeah
that's what i mean yeah
so i don't think she's i don't think
she's
like she's sad mentally i think she
might just be cocked a little bit well
she's now stri stands like 79 i think my
dad is 76. and streisand is like like i
i'm out in my garden like she's
completely with her she's at 79. 79. she
looks amazing yeah is she still she can
she still hold a note oh strikes i saw
her two summers ago or three summers ago
with my aunt cindy live at in chicago
was it i mean she can sing really oh yes
she didn't she didn't lose that many
steps not at all wow streisand can sing
i mean really she came out and it's the
first note we all started crying which
tries hands i'm not a big fan of
shredding but but i like her as an actor
but what is her i just mean her music's
not for me that's all what is her big
song she has a bunch so are you laughing
at it
just your explanations
[Music]
memories yes that's not from cats right
no you're thinking of memory all alone
in the moonlight yes when i saw the
movie as ridiculous as it was i cried a
little bit when the chiefs well first of
all they did they did jennifer hudson
dirty when you saw cats the new cats you
could movie the new cats the movie i
thought was absurd you cried
you cried to the newspaper tried it
memory a little bit i cried when i saw
cats live at memory because it it i did
it's like
what were you gonna say about james
corden by the way oh so james corden why
are we glossing over there why are we
glossing over there
warby parker if you don't know it maybe
you're living under a rock i'm not
trying to be offensive i just i hear
about it all the time i own a bunch of
pairs it's affordable lenses at
reasonable prices and they're
fashionable that's my take on it i'm not
even reading copies i hear you can i
tell you what will be parker's about
please committed to providing
exceptional vision care online and in
stores
offering eyeglasses sunglasses eye exams
and contact lenses
glasses starting at 95 bucks including
prescript prescription lenses which i
love because i got to tell you before
a company like this came along when i
had to get new glasses boom boom boom
reaching your wallet
it was 350 a pop 100 yeah 800 and you
couldn't have multiple people 500 past
that by the way aren't worth it you
couldn't have multiple pairs sure you
said if i'm if i'm going with the green
frames i'm going with the green frames
you start to pay three four hundred
dollars you could now get four different
looks four different pairs all
prescription for yourself and this is
the coolest thing you don't have to go
to the store exactly you go online and
you sign on and you could they have this
whole program
uh where you try them free at home it's
called the try on program you order five
pairs of glasses for free to try and at
home for five days is zero obligation to
buy they ship free and include the
prepaid shipping level label to return
them right so basically what you're
looking at here is you take the quiz
online you get the box of frames you try
them on you decide which ones you want
and then you order them and that's it
it's so easy
it's amazing it's so easy it's amazing
warby parker
is committed to making this convenient
for you
all right so here's what you're going to
do you want to try five pair of glasses
uh at home for free
here's what you do you go to
warbyparker.com
warby is w-a-r-b-y
parker is
p-a-r-k-e-r english language dot com
slash taste buds try five different
frames at home for free at
warbyparker.com
taste buds
folks welcome
folks
yeah
welcoming audible to the podcast listen
to the new audible original summer in
argyll which was created and written by
nate odenkirk and his father emmy award
winner bob oden who you happen to be in
scenes with on television yes uh pop in
your earbuds visit the town of argyle
ohio it's a place that celebrates the
spirit of close enough and enjoys both
an annual hot dog eating contest
and an annual murder
hear about argyle's darkest secret the
mysterious death of a magnificent bowler
who never bowled and instead warmed the
bench the way argyle folk love explore
the town's hot spots like the dmv that's
also a fancy restaurant the world's
largest lost and found or gets stitched
up by the local surgeon who's also a
magician soon sounds fun you'll be in
stitches from performances by a cast
that includes comedy greats like david
cross
awesome seeing them together again tim
robinson pretty cool paul tompkins
another mr show alumni and more this is
one hot dog murder comedy with
everything on it visit audible.com
summer and argyle and listen now hashtag
summer and argyle
with the problem
what i would identify as the with the
problem with cordon is
is he seems like the friend
that when you called him to talk [ __ ]
would be like
i love them though you know what i mean
i don't mean this no because i think i'm
not
[ __ ] and i said i can't i can't do this
one i can't do that and it makes me
resent you like i have no
problem no it's gordon or a family but
they're they're gigging you know i agree
i agree but there's
there's something that's not authentic
it only goes so far fallon to me
seems like a happy drunk
so i don't have a problem with fallon
fallon seems like a guy that is like
whatever man you know
i'm fine with that i'm fine with kimmel
kimmel seems like a real guy colbert
seems like the suck up to the teacher
see i disagree and and cordon to me
seems like the guy that won't say
anything negative about anybody and he
started trouble
when he hosted the awards for saying
something or or right after uh
he got in trouble for something
in trouble we're not seven i hate i know
so and so got in trouble i'm not on the
playground i'm an adult i didn't get in
trouble you didn't like what i said
move on let's move on of course of
course that's my take on late night bill
burst said the best thing recently he's
like i know we're mad at words i said in
a strip mall but like there's garbage in
the ocean the size of alaska yeah yeah
what are we mad at and i was like that's
like the best way to put it like there
is garbage in the ocean the size of
alaska yeah
yeah
are we going to argue about this or not
what is going on
reflect on that
well reflected we all reflected that we
we better do the chance all right
i mean okay ready yeah
no matter what happens i love you no
matter what happens i love you no matter
what happens i love you time to be a
t-t-l-e bunch all right here we go
everyone has the same reaction and i
just like to say that we we like it it's
the reason that felt homophobic yeah
yeah i felt like not for some reason
by the way as i do this yeah
yeah cover how dare you
the chants help us help us not take the
tension during the argument
okay
great
i'm glad you two feel good about this
agreement are you not having fun i'm
having a blast are you out of your mind
it's great i'm having a good time
actually you know what's funny um we we
all see each other all the time you know
doing spots in the city but it always is
like a little bit of like a on the go
you might talk for 10 minutes but then i
go you go i think or any other in here
but it is nice to have an extended
sit-down as if we were actually hanging
out we haven't gotten to the arguing yet
but it's nice to hang out with friends i
don't do it often it's great i i
literally the podcast is the only way i
do it i know i mean that sincerely it is
great
i love
[Music]
outside of you matteo is probably the
only friend i have that i actually have
sit down dinners with yeah i will often
go over to sal's house and have a full
sit-down dinner with which i told you
about we should all do that together
yeah yeah but you're out outside of that
you
keith dante
it was so fun wasn't it it's usually the
five of us right yeah and uh it's five
right yeah and we'll usually go out and
have a nice sit down dinner together and
you're one of the few people on earth
outside of this guy
that i would i'm willing to spend a
hundred fifty dollars to eat differently
that's keith keith where i'm not going
yeah i'm not going like i'll just meet
you at lenny's sandwiches i don't give a
[ __ ] dude come on you know what i mean
or let's get a coffee it's like no let's
go down when it rained on us yeah it was
awesome i have some nice memories yeah i
do too yeah good times all right well
now you're you are our enemy now okay
deal
[Laughter]
an easy position i've been in many times
doing cannolis versus claire's right uh
not croissants and uh
matteo has cannolis which but you know
by the by they are really good but
eclairs
we're thinking he's going to take
cannoli out i think it'll take it out
yes but but as
as our guest
we'd like to give you the opening
arguments sure as to why cannolis in
your opinion
are the best
elongated dessert
[Laughter]
in the world of elongated desserts i
don't know how to put it it's
really the parallel penises they're kind
of lovely that's not what i meant
they're that's not but they use that in
this song
like
he'll put the cannoli in your hand
they're talking about if you marry the
instruments with the flute in your hand
yeah they're talking about children sing
this song well at weddings it's like a
dog you know what talent is we're also
yeah yeah but it's it's it's a it's you
know
like you know figure out what song i
want to sing with you
what
huh you're going to harmonize no not now
but i just another type just
oh
[Music]
uh jersey easy money with rodney
dangerfield no film on staten island
what's the song he sings at his
daughter's wedding you're thinking the
godfather where they sing chela luna no
yeah what's the song he sings in the
backyard where they're all packed in the
square
that's it
it is that right yeah yeah yeah yeah are
you guys just doing the english version
okay anyway all right can only opening
arguments
[Music]
a little bit of jessica in my life a
little bit you want to do it let's do it
one more two three four five
i think he's still wearing that zoot
suit um
he walks around in it look i don't mind
eclairs i guess is as a sense of like a
cultural thing okay great i understand
this is important culture there's a
clear chocolate clear
but cannoli has a i like things with a
specific point of view a cannoli is very
specific in other words chips are no
chips i say no chips okay so and i'm
talking like real systems oh really no
chocolate chips all right maybe some
pistachio outside no dried fruit in it
but i think a cannoli you've got great
textures okay so you got the hard
crunchy shell with the soft ricotta in
the middle and then a little bit of the
pistachio on the outside so you're
getting a variation of textures that are
both sweet that are both um sort of
cinnamony with the shell and then you
get the nuttiness of pistachio if i may
i'm not done with that no i just i just
want to compliment something you said
yeah sure
you you never
texture because it's all too soft or it
can get mushy or it feels well can
always get mushy my friend yeah but if
you have it we're talking about how it's
if it's presented to you in the way it
should be presented right i mean you can
get kind of a bite in the dough
that they cook or bake rather with with
an eclair but it feels lazy to me
because i'm just going to slap some
chocolate on top and shove something in
the middle i don't know how many grinder
dates have ended that way
a lazy top so
i think
i think a cannoli it's a little more
dedication
listen to me if you're talking about it
both in there in the greatest form you
cannot disrespect the eclair the eclair
is a fresh flaky pastry with i don't
think it's flaky i don't think it's even
nice
enough
i mean
absolutely yeah
and that chocolate on top i mean that is
i mean that is the kicker it's like the
the bow on top of the the president's
cream to just yeah to make something and
then say you know what i'll make this
better slather chocolate on top children
do this with cookies
babe babe they do that with cannolis too
i see chocolate i don't know
i've been to some authentic italian
bakeries in in new york and they have
they absolutely have chocolate i haven't
been to sicily where they are from i'm
discussing the sicilian cannoli
but i will tell you also that not
everybody has the taste for the cannoli
it can have a bit of a sour
taste to it it shouldn't but i
understand what you're saying right
because you're talking like ricotta
sheep's milk but that's why i'm saying
it's an evolved delicate advanced
dessert
created in the beautiful lands of sicily
that sometimes is an acquired taste so
you appreciate it more once you actually
get it but i don't think you have to
acquire a taste for an eclair no but
it's hacked to say anyone can eat this
if a child and a man in his early
hundreds eat this they're gonna say
sugar yum that's an eclair i don't agree
and i'll tell you that if something is
widely popular why is it hack
it just means that it appears
also too and i i will say you're wrong
because when i was a child i thought
eclairs were disgusting i didn't have hi
french fry when i got older when i got
older around the time i started to
appreciate the cannoli was when i also
started to appreciate the eclair you
know i think they're very similar now
what i do is everybody
also an amazing fresh batch of custard
the custard is uh is the hero but then
the the the dough and the chocolate but
just combined for the pun i'm telling
you it's mixing three textures and at
least two textures and three flavors
together they're too similar they're
fighting against each other rather than
with each other in other words you eat a
cannoli i know the difference between
the three flavors that are going into my
mouth so i can appreciate them on
different levels if i'm eating an eclair
this is i'm just shoving dough with
chocolate no no no no no no no and we're
giving it a french house suddenly it's
it's i also think you're not french i
also
i also think you're putting way too fine
a point on the three flavors of the
cannoli okay the two flavors of the
cannoli let's be honest that you're
getting are the cream the creamy cheese
whatever
even in the cheese and the shell now
hold on because here's itself it's
ricotta with sugar and balanced
correctly gives you
a multitude of flavor okay so what i i
would say this this is what i love about
the cannoli it is the egg roll of
desserts it's an egg roll it's a flaky
delicious dessert you never said that
why
even i was like i don't know if i've
ruined
i just really wanted to get you to laugh
i'm trying so hard to get you to laugh
but you're so enjoying you thoroughly
good
you know what you are you're the
opposite of james corden whoever your
guest is they are your enemies that's
what i wanted
keith robinson told me a story speaking
keith roberts is the most evil man on
earth yes
told me a story once where he was
co-hosting wanda sykes tv show this is a
true story he was the coast wanted sex
tv show and he was reprimanded several
times because the producers will pull
him aside after tables and go keith you
can't tell the guests to shut up and
that they're stupid
you stink
ah he stinks
he stinks several times yelled at for
that
i love that about keith i i i do i i've
always and this is not a knock i've
always thought of the uh cannoli as the
egg roll of a of a dessert it's very for
some reason reminiscent and egg roll to
me tag me it's the flaky crap crusty
thing but it's not clay it's a crunchy
an egg roll
a cannoli will i end up on your shirt
you bite it it's flaking onto your shirt
take me in not flaking though crunching
okay there's a difference but you you
get my point let me tell you something
cheese cardboard and cheese the italian
right the the the clam shaped italian
thing where it's the pastry with the
cheese inside of it my mom called it
cardboard and cheese that's what they
called in philly it's kind of wow
he's not even hiding their trash they're
like
but
[Laughter]
that's uh that's it's clam shaped
clamshell shaped and with uh cream
cheese in it i don't know
if you saw it you go oh that well what
i'm saying my point is just but an egg
hold on look at an egg roll is hot and
an egg roll is compact tight and egg
roll is meant for dipping and putting in
your mouth a cannoli is delicate he is
the king of bad metaphors and parallels
you don't think the shell of the egg
roll is
necessarily what i'm saying that's what
i'm saying but let me say this i think
we're talking about a downside of a
cannoli i think cannoli uh suffers from
the same downside as a taco which you
could bite your first bite into it and
then it just falls apart completely i'm
not going to argue you're right i'm not
going to argue the the transportation
drops
to that you're just picking up slops of
crunchy broken things you're getting it
into your mouth cannoli egg rolls are a
thing
thank you
thank you for being with your friends
your italians are involved
down the road and back again
[Music]
the biggest gift would be for
you did you did i heard i
[Laughter]
[Music]
and he rips off his wig i [ __ ] love
it i'm making that today's theme song
great all right
um i'll tell you nothing about cannoli i
am a dunker through and through and you
can't dunk a cannoli
yeah but canoes are not meant to dunk in
other words i like cake and i'm not
dunking it in anything but it's a pastry
and most pastries you know one of the
things you love is the drink it's a
coffee this is not true i do not believe
most pastries are meant to be dipped in
things they meant to be eaten that way
thank you i argue this with him all the
time he's just don't believe me you son
of a [ __ ] you've been going against me
the whole day my plan
my plan is working we can't watch it two
seconds ago when i did it was it was
just harmonized together
i just made the egg roll emails you went
against i can't only speak my truth what
happened to your stupid
joe
he loves to dunk and i don't give a [ __ ]
this is we're together
you just went against me because it was
a stupid thing
this the closest you've gotten to being
in the nba oh i dunk
i assure you
i assure you i don't you're ducking
because because this is making me
nervous
please all right who's up by the way
who's out there is it paul or lucas
oh you're opening
no somebody came into the barn is
unloading something they came in to tell
us to shut up well you're unloading a
lot
oh it's lucas all right
luke is a good man he's out there right
now all right that's it babe that's it
are we in the civil war
[Laughter]
i don't want your civil war
pouring whiskey hey ruger good man
i wrote my emma this morning don't turn
against me babe you turned against me
two seconds ago and said to mateo and i
quote he does this in the most
dismissive you're impossible you're
right yeah so own your [ __ ] no mine own
your [ __ ] no i just owned it oh my god
sweet lord
what else do i expect from a man who
wears his own face on his chest oh don't
do that it's new immersion it says
nicholas case
i only wore it because i need to pay my
mortgage oh yeah yeah yeah cause you're
not making a lot of money oh don't go
down you son of a [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
you son of a [ __ ] the tv show that's
kept the lights on it's true tv true tv
wouldn't be a network anymore
shirts if i give you one of these bad
boys and you wear it whoo but the shirts
will move i don't think they will i
think i'm going to get you a smaller
stat now it's going to be like is this
going to make me gay i'm not wearing
this shirt no not at all i'm gonna get
you a small you wear it around town all
right you're wearing around town and you
make no apologies for it and i i'll let
you i'll give you a ten percent
i like how you the caveats like make no
apologies for this
listen here's the thing here's the thing
i think sal has made some great points
about the cannoli and i think that he is
absolutely right i have never i've had
many cannolis
and i love cannolis but i have no
cannoli it's already plural i've never
had
put the claws away relax
relax
i've never had a cannoli that i even the
best can always have ever had
i never had a cannoli that i didn't have
to eat like this
because the powdered sugar the whatever
that's like saying i don't like fried
wings i don't like wings because they're
messy
sometimes the best food you have our
apples are messy okay i mean
you make a great point and i actually
made that same point in the last episode
we were arguing i said i said to mark
norman i said that's like saying you
don't like ribs because they get sauce
on your mouth right or whatever
i i hear you didn't you pick honey
uh yes the messiest of all three mm-hmm
the messiest of all three oh no i think
that's six everywhere i think nutella is
no it's nutella pick up done it's
chocolate
let's stick on that
for a second
i so i hear you about the cannoli i make
this argument all the time sometimes
things take effort and that makes them
more worthwhile i hear you but the
beauty of an eclair
is you pop that out of the box
it is hot dog hot dog bun soft
it's so soft it's decadent and it's
three flavors it's dough
cream or custard and chocolate frosting
and that thing and that chocolate
power you just just the kick it needs at
the end from front to back
it doesn't fall apart it is so
like together the whole time i've never
had something that creamy and delicious
that is that
uh concise and and neat well i'll
introduce you to some men but i think
i think you know it's like if we're
talking about the
the messiness of something then this
disqualifies almost all good food that's
a very good so i don't think are we
going to argue
are we going to argue on taste
and sophistication or are we going to
argue on
because it's
eclairs are coming from it's in a
plastic tube but it's not nothing you
know what i mean gogurt is you don't see
the claire you don't eat the casing of
ghosts at my house recently that brought
sorry cannoli i bought i had a guest in
my house recently i poured cannoli
shells with the bag of cannoli cream and
you make your own as you go listen
you bring up a good point you bring it
back
i love the nachos the shells that you
get yourself though i have a great i
have a great you make a great point
someone comes to your house you're
having a dinner party you bring dessert
and they have a box with them and they
open up that box if you see 15 cannoli
or 15 eclairs what are you most excited
for i i think the eclair ah you are you
are just the eclair i'm a monster when i
when i'm more fresher
i actually might what i feel in my heart
is
a more like delight you ever see that
song
i'm more impressed by the cannoli right
because you're
but i'm more excited
about the eclair are you more excited
about champagne or diet coke also and i
got to tell you this
and i gotta tell you guys
but i gotta tell you this too
i can eat two eclairs and be like i had
two eclairs all right it's dessert i
shouldn't eat dessert whatever i eat two
cannolis i want to throw myself off a
building well first of all
i feel so guilty the amount you consume
hold on a second the amount you consume
of the dessert has nothing to do with
how good it is he's correct he's really
brilliant i mean what is this stop
you're wrong
with him
stop it i'm just saying stop stop
laughing these are counter arguments
that make you all the time you can't
count your arguments bro don't worry she
said there were great counter arguments
well i'm sorry i'm saying what he's
saying is he's dismantling your account
arguments and why i have made these
arguments no no
his count arguments are arguments i make
to you all the time when we're battling
and you dismiss them dismiss them now
well you know i idiot each battle and
its own i take each battle in its own
spread
let's sing another what do we think is
more famous in the world eclairs i think
cannoli eclairs i think it's associated
with you know what how many famous
famous movie of all time leave the gun
take the cannoli they didn't say eclair
leave the gun take
how many can only sold the united states
a year how about worldwide
worldwide let's do a worldwide let's do
it worldwide worldwide
well we hit it just we hit a wall right
there we're waiting for our statistics
yeah where is that because i also want
to get a nutrition
nutritional account after this well
nutrition
with the arguments
why are you acting like we don't do this
every week no i'm saying i could he's
going to dismantle the nutrition
argument i know yes because we're not
it's we're already over desserts and
we're going with two nutritional
arguments yeah i can see this doesn't
even begin to make sense i'll tell you
why it doesn't the last thing when you
order an eclair or no the last thing you
or you think about where you order
claire or canola is i wonder what the
nutritional i'll tell you why i'll tell
you why it's a dessert i'll tell you why
the nutritional account uh
makes sense
because it's the same reason why i
rarely order a cannoli
halfway through it i feel like i'm going
to go into a coma i don't feel like that
from an eclair it does and my point is
is that it's a heavier the cannoli is a
heavier richer more caloric dessert
and i think that that is a negative i
disagree i didn't find my cannoli space
until i was older yeah i used to buy
cannolis as a kid and be like i just
don't get this you can't i acquired it
but at claire's it was a home run for my
first bite it wasn't you also can't say
you weren't kidding
kids love ding dongs and old men love
ding dong i love ding dong it's a sweet
treat that's soft do you think you're
awesome it's easy to go a cannoli you
have to think about it i will tell you
but it doesn't mean it's a better food
it doesn't look listen stravinsky is a
more complex music than guns and roses
correct doesn't mean that it's better
disagree doesn't mean that it's better
so my point is this my point is this
with uh i love cheesecake okay
but i think chocolate cake is superior
why
not just a flavor thing i also think
that i can eat a slice of chocolate cake
and not feel terrible but you're gonna
pick and choose my batter
your personal experience with how you
eat has nothing to do with the foods
themselves as a stamp now bring back the
argument for the corned beef ham cheese
episode corned beef
corn beef is absolutely strange
you're eating you're just salt you're
our personal experience comes into play
otherwise what do we have sure but i'm
also saying as a universal experience
we're talking about two desserts your
personal experience my personal
experience will declare it does not
satisfy me and i leave thinking i could
also add a hershey's bar and felt the
same fine but that's but exactly so that
means your personal experience
has a specific point of view that you
have and you think that was a cannoli
but that means your personal experience
counts which is why you're arguing for
to make conversations i think an eclair
has a cannoli beet
mushy peanut sticks not mushy
i don't know where you're getting this
mushy thing because
if you see a little tower of eclairs
with fresh chocolate on them and stuff
like that and a cannoli if you put them
on the table you set them down to the
party i think people are reaching for
the canola i think they're going to has
a secret ingredient you just said
cannoli i'll give you a slip thank you
i'll give you another pro i'll give you
another pro eclair argument
longevity you can have a cl you could
have a box of eclairs for a couple days
they're going to be all right that
cannoli you don't hit that on this you
can eat it again you can eat it monkey
from 1955. no
what is this
i think the argument is about can you
mark what is a better dessert when it's
sitting in front of you and you're
eating it not can i put this in the
cabinet for six weeks i don't think that
happens
six weeks it has to because that's like
saying well then it has to do with the
construction and a cannoli i would argue
that but struck it better of the night
will not be as deliciously edible as it
was at the beginning but again i don't
believe that this is a party argument
because basically what you're saying is
is the longevity more important or when
it's presented to you and pretty much
i'm not saying i'm not saying i'm not
saying that longevity is important maybe
it was the wrong word to use what i'm
saying though is longevity to me speaks
to construction and speaks to qua
there's a quality to be had in
construction and when i can say that
this thing holds itself together for a
longer period of time there's some value
in that to me yeah the value is that you
can eat it tomorrow but my my argument
is if i order cannoli at a restaurant i
don't think box is up and i'll eat it
tomorrow is i want to eat this now okay
so we're arguing over the the dish
presented to you and that time to eat
do you look at it and think um how will
this taste
go for some levity yes
i admit
that the best cannoli
is better than the best declare
there you go i admit it but
on the whole i don't know if i agree
with that i go claire on the whole i
don't know
no no more times out of none i go eclair
but i know what i hate when they try to
sell you the little mini eclairs or i'm
sorry the middle mini cannolis or
cannolis in
a market that are from a bakery they
always are a disappointment but i'm
going to tell you i got it that's like
getting an eclair at like publix i got
to tell you
this is a knock against the cannoli i
like a mini cannoli why because i can
eat it and not feel like [ __ ] yeah a
whole cannoli you've got to be i went to
an italian coffee shop down on friday
with paul italia my dear friend and
partner here
joey rose's 174 remington
we went to an italian coffee shop
we had some it was it's awesome it's a
classic
italy style coffee shop you stand at the
counter you drink your espresso
they have fresh baked pastries
we got mini cannolis
and they had full canolis i got a mini
won't my espresso why because it was the
middle of the day and i was like if i
eat a whole cannoli right now it doesn't
help us i'm gonna be tired can i say
something first of all i'm glad that
cannolis of any shape are good for you
and secondly
i've had okay so i'm not not just not so
proposed but having a real canola in
sicily
is very different from the experience of
having it here an american cannoli is
different just like pizzas these people
were italian they were actually
my cousins from sicily were with me
yesterday at an italian restaurant
yeah i know so but here hear me out
having you my gender i said you people
[Laughter]
having a real cannoli in sicily if your
mind comes out when you get into the
background it's much it's a lighter
experience and a fresher experience
similar to having carbonara in new york
is different than having carbonara in
rome
so a real cannoli in its truest form i'm
sure like an eclair in france is
different than it is here uh so you have
a real cannoli in sicily
i understand that so let me ask you this
if you could come down from your special
pedestal no no i'm i'm
here and i'm comfortable joey rose where
you have where you have cannolis only in
the finest markets of palermo i'm sorry
would you prefer i have them in philly
next to your car
where do you want me to have the cannoli
i'm gonna have cannoli where the cannoli
is from so maybe you dig yourself out
from your oscars just like spring
spaghetti's from italy right stolen from
china
so actually the first grows once again
first of all the first pasta because
pasta noodles are two different things
pasta the first pasta was found as a
lasagna in ancient rome which pre-dates
where they found it in general no
columbus discovered america
it's outrageous what you italians claim
[Laughter]
all right let's pimp read us some
comments this was fun this is great i
had a great time this is great
read us some comments
um
there's a reason uh eclairs are sold at
every 711 across the country it's trash
[Laughter]
you have to have class to enjoy a
cannoli you can get a cannoli i love
them what's their name
that was uh the ham sandwich okay the
hamstrings
all right
uh listen i love eclair as much as the
next guy but nothing makes me want to
drape an italian flag around me faster
than a fresh hey
um
let's see
we might be in trouble here cannoli was
in the godfather a lot of that hey
you said it eclairs are elongated boston
cream donuts the superior donut makes
them the super tastier treat for the win
okay interesting wow bringing boston
into the conversation we go from sicily
to boston in this conversation somebody
just says shout out little debbie for
giving us better options
oh okay both
if that person was face down in a river
i'd keep walking yeah
oh boy uh cannolis are too phallic
okay
and eclair's shaped like what
what an arm
an idiot
uh sleep [ __ ]
always always feels trashier eating food
with my hands
okay well you eat who eats you both
weeds in a clear with a fork and knife
like mr peter
yeah
one of the greatest sci-fi watches i saw
a guy the other day eating m ms with a
spoon
a lot of the greatest seifed lines a lot
of people are saying cannoli has more
variety
oh that's [ __ ] that's true no it's
not you get a chocolate clarification
chocolate-covered one or you put
chocolate chips in it no they got tons
of different kinds all right a lot of
people are saying the movie van wilder
ruined both desserts for them i don't
even know i picture semen involved
something like that that was like that
was that like uh
ryan reynolds like college frat type of
movie isn't that based on burke crusher
apparently oh maybe maybe apparently i
was confused though because ryan
reynolds kept his shirt on
folks
actually i don't think he did
he was naked in that movie actually
climbing out of window naked
i'm just saying no um i love bert bert
hi hi
hello come on guys this is like picking
a favorite child
by the way every parent has a favorite
child go on true
let's not all lie to ourselves and say
like i love them all the same you don't
you don't yeah i agree with you there
eclairs are just hot dog donuts
that's very good all right
a lot of people are saying this has an
east coast bias
which one i don't know they just just
said this poll i would say the winner i
would say the winner is the first one
once again it's weird that the last few
episodes has been the first tweet is the
winner the the seven eleven oh god i
like this one i dragged my nuts over
broken glass for a single bite of a
cannoli
all right
give that the win wow that guy who is
this cannolis uh underscore
c-r-e-a-t-i-i-o-n-n-s
all right follow that person
and here we go humble pie this is the
humble pie segment where we just so you
know somebody eats it
just you know wait wait wait wait wait
do your plugs right now oh when does
this come out
two weeks
three weeks three weeks okay so no i'm
four weeks
oh yeah
i will be performing uh at the park west
theatre in chicago we added a second
show and it's almost sold out so please
um house of comedy bank vancouver april
7th and 9th uh detroit april 22nd 23rd
and columbus april 24th for all tickets
go to matteolancomedy.com or follow me
on instagram at matteo lane i love it i
love it i love it i love it boom
all right you ready now whoever wins you
have to if you so if you win you have to
say i still love you okay
uh can we do our plugs you do your plugs
yeah new dates just announced besides
the beacon on may 14th which i need you
to go to i got la after wilton on may
22nd uh san diego on may 21st and the
new dates just announced on sale now
louisville evansville tulsa oklahoma
city rochester syracuse milwaukee
minneapolis and hampton beach savile
county committee that's way when does
this episode come out
okay well perfect i'm the 25th well
folks here's plugs i hope you saw me in
philly last weekend
and uh at south by southwest but i will
be
in at the irvine improv in california in
april and then i will be going down to
san diego to do a bunch of shows right
after that uh and then in may i'm coming
back to austin to the creek and cave
i'll also be doing the come and take it
festival in houston in may
uh go to joederosainfo.com
for all ticket sales uh and information
i'll be in fort collins
uh
in colorado right uh texas i think it's
for college
i don't know
well wherever the hell fort collins is
i'll be there at the comedy fort in june
come out to see that and then also if
you're in new york come see us here at
joey rose's 174 rivington street open
tuesday through sunday
joeyrosesnyc.com for all info one last
thing for the pod we never asked this
but we're starting to now because it
makes a difference subscribe to our
youtube channel at no press
like and rate us on itunes and spotify
it does help us if you love the podcast
and you wanna help us that's what you
can do
all right guys ready eleven thousand
votes eleven thousand ah that's a lot
that's more than the last one yeah here
we go all right start from the bottom oh
no wait there's not three there's two
okay
here we go uh is it close quinn is it
close so the winner has 56 oh close
and the winner is canola
we've lost the last two weeks we guess
oh my god you're all bastard people
he didn't weep i can't believe it it was
close it was a good battle
bennett
yes we love you too baby okay
what fun
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two foods gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man